this is the FAA I want everybody to know
just just last week a freaking door flew
off of an airplane because some guy
didn't do their jobs right so listen to
this and I'm going to break down what
you said and a little boy lost his shirt
and a boy lost his shirt God forbid I
hope it wasn't his lucky one all the
passengers lost listen to the
language okay they're hiring severe not
mild not regular but severe intellectual
disabilities which translates to dumb
Psych atric disorders crazy and various
physical and mental conditions mentally
let's say for what it is and by
the way that who you guys just saw was
Scott Kirby Rob I sent you a link of who
he is he said 50% are going to be women
people of color and lgbtq Community it's
called United calls it flying with pride